the oil price is sold off quite
dramatically during the last ten
ministers so we're about two and a half
percent lower it's just a classic case
of bond the rumors sell on the fact
probably yes it is a classic case and
there's two things to look at yes that
the oil markets the OPEC non-opec deal
which took 1.8 million barrels out of
the market in terms of production cuts
managed to get the production overhang
out of the system and Venezuela is all
but falling off a cliff now with Iran if
there are further sanctions on Iran
which it looks there will be the de
market is getting tighter but what we
also have to see is that not everybody
will be as impressed with US sanctions
maybe the Europeans or other countries
China and some other countries may very
well sort of say ok we will buy Iranian
oh so for the short run I'm not worried
that here on Ian's oil will be off the
market but in the medium to longer term
I am concerned because Iran desperately
needs investment and it also needs
access to Western technology you know
these many years of sanctions have left
the oil sector wheeling in being very
uncompetitive and under invested so this
is this is not a good thing for in the
short run for oil markets maybe not such
big impact but psychological it will be
markets are psychological so they will
react but in the longer medium to longer
term this is not a good thing Oh Sonam
how sustainable is this deal without the
United States is it a dead duck
we very hard especially if the u.s. goes
for a hard exit reimposing all
nuclear-related sanctions and penalizes
international companies for doing
business in Iran it will be very
difficult if they do the soft exit
though there is an option where the
Europeans and Russia and China can
protect the deal so that's the thing we
don't exactly know what Trump is going
to announce in terms of possible
sanctions or not reports suggests he's
going to go for the hard exit which
would close the door and make protecting
the deal very difficult for the
Europeans and for Russia and China it
will also put immense pressure on
President rouhani who has
Bengt on this deal as his legacy and the
opportunity to save the Iranian economy
well Khalil you mentioned foreign firms
doing business in Iran I mean total for
example the French oil major one of the
world's biggest oil and gas producers
they've actually they're trying to
develop a gas field in Iran what happens
- they're trying to develop the largest
gas field in the world the South Pass
field and and the the oil Minister has
come out mrs. Anggun a has come out and
said if if if they if they want to they
can't pull the investment or or you know
they can leave but we will keep the
investment so that is tough and sort of
having worked for multinational
companies not just you know oil
companies also GE and having worked in
America it's very tough once you know
you are on the sanctions list one are
you want the countries on that
restricted list it's very very tough for
European or other companies to still do
business in the US if they don't adhere
to the sanctions so it's gonna be it's
gonna be very very tough so what options
do such businesses have chances are most
businesses are going to turn their backs
on Iran because they can't walk away
from the American market and the Iranian
market is small and it's rife with
challenges getting businesses going in
Iran is tough then you have to contend
with the Revolutionary Guard Corps also
interfering you have to deal with
regulation that is outdated so the ease
of doing business in Iran does not
outweigh the American penalties and
opportunities is this going to be a
danger that this drives it ran into the
arms of say Russia and China possibly
very possibly already Iran looks to
those countries as protecting it in in
the past and the UN Security Council and
I think that relationship is only going
to grow stronger as Iran sees those two
countries as its lifeline both
economically and politically what was
the thing that was most wrong with the
deal was it the fact that it didn't hold
Iran to restrictions and developing
ballistic missiles I mean that's
something that's got the the kritis that
the people criticized it was was it was
it was the lack of
it was the it's the temporary
restriction it's ten years for one thing
15 years for another thing it was the
fact that he could still develop
ballistic missiles and you know some of
the countries like Israel who got very
hot hot under the collar over the deal
things have changed in the last few
years because since Russia has come into
Syria
with its very good air defense system
it's it's all but impossible for them to
go and actually take things out so
things have changed and when you look to
your point when you look at Iran China
and Russia when you look at how Iran is
working with Russia in Syria when you
look at the whole belt and Road concept
of the Chinese and how they're working
with Iran on that yes the West really
has to think do we want that sort of
unholy alliance of China Russia and and
Iran sitting in the Middle East what's
the best-case scenario from here
painting paint as a cheery picture I
think that's a bit hard right now we're
on the brink of hearing some bad news
the best-case scenario is that the
Europeans pull some sort of Hail Mary
pass and managed to convince Iran to
come back to the table and improve upon
the deal maybe a more for more scenario
but it's going to be very difficult to
convince the Iranians that are already
very factionalized among the political
elite and are already very frustrated by
the fact that the deal hasn't paid off
to come back to the table because they
see the US as having moved the goal
posts on this jcpoa Iran has been
compliant and they're gonna have to
really struggle not to respond in kind
and restart their nuclear program so the
risk I guess is also you get a hard line
taking rouhani's places around him
absolutely not just at the presidency
level but we should also expect perhaps
hardliners coming back and taking the
parliament and this could also have a
negative effect when we think about
succession to replace the supreme leader
Ali Khamenei I was really struck or
nearly you said just now that Iran can
carry on selling their oil in gas I mean
isn't it surely they'll be able to sell
it with impunity to countries like India
and China they're not gonna be too
worried about busting US sanctions I
think they will not be too worried and
probably ways of doing this in
the Indians are getting closer to t2 the
Americans so there will be a little bit
more cautious but the Chinese are not
and when you just look at the growing
Chinese influence you know globally and
also militarily in the South China Sea
and so on that should surely worried the
West and I would like to take make one
parent one parallel which is which is
Qatar you know which is now being as
isolated by the Gulf when you were in
Qatar two years ago you heard English
and and and Arabic now when you go to
cut are you here Turkish you here first
see you Iranian and you here you here
Chinese so so things have changed
Cornelia Maya sanam Vakeel thanks very
much for joining me